halflife Alex nails so much of what
makes the series great and VR elevates
its best qualities even veterans such as
myself wish I knew a few of these things
before playing so here's what you need
to know before starting half life Alex
upgrade the pistol SMG and shotgun four
laser sights ASAP throughout half-life
Alex you'll collect resin which serves
as a currency for upgrading your slim
arsenal however you need to be smart
about how you spend resin since upgrades
are costly we'd recommend saving your
resin to outfit your guns with laser
sights ASAP and avoiding the reflex
sight since is not as helpful amy and vr
can be difficult but the laser sight
shows exactly where your shots will land
for the pistol and SMG as for the
shotgun the laser sight is also very
helpful because it paints a circle of
how your shot will spread and since
shotgun shells are quite rare you'll
want to make sure that each shot hits
most of their upgrades will come down to
preference but the shotguns grenade
launcher and the smg's multi clip
upgrade are easy to recommend each
weapon has its best use case you may
have a limited loadout but it's just
enough to get by and half life Alex's
combat scenarios and we have some
recommendations for what to use for
specific encounters a few examples the
shotgun is great against combine
especially heavies the pistol is great
for slow-moving zombies and clipping
weak points off ant lions and the SMG is
best suited for other combine soldiers
drones and larger crowds of weaker
enemies use objects in the environment
against barnacles early in the game ammo
will be hard to come by and you'll
encounter the ceiling dwelling barnacles
your instinct might be to shoot and get
them out of the way they take three to
four pistol shots to kill but you can
save that ammo by tossing any ol object
into its tongue to keep it occupied for
a few seconds giving you a window of
opportunity to get by some instances
have red barrels or gas canisters in the
environment and if you get a barnacle to
eat one it'll explode it's pretty
satisfying to see them blow to pieces
but take a step back first so you don't
get hurt and don't forget to check the
aftermath for any ammo that they might
have dropped shoot headcrab zombies in
the headcrab half-life veterans may know
this all too well but if you're not
aware there's a proper way to kill a
zombie aim for the head crab attached to
it and you'll kill the zombie and
Krabbe simultaneously if you shoot the
zombie in the body the headcrab will
survive and come at you this will take
up more of your ammo and make your life
that much harder so aim for the headcrab
store grenades and syringes in your
wrists you may forget from time to time
that Alex can store health syringes and
grenades in her wrist pockets simply
hold the object near your wrists to put
it away and you can grab it at any time
remember this will come in clutch for
heated encounters especially when the
game ramps up the challenge in the later
half pull grenades using the gravity
gloves combine soldiers will sometimes
throw grenades at you but if you just
threw them right back at them you can do
that with the gravity gloves just pull
the grenade in as you would any other
object and toss it you'll save yourself
from getting hurt and you'll inflict
damage on enemies and if you're clever
enough you can pluck the grenade off an
unsuspecting or dead soldiers belt use a
combo of walking and teleporting for
movement and other mobility options
half-life Alex incorporates multiple
movement styles and you should go with
whatever's most comfortable for you we
found that the most effective method
gameplay-wise
was to use a combination of continuous
analogue locomotion alongside
teleportation teleportation can get you
out of a bind fast and covers more
ground
however analog movement can be more
precise when trying to get specific
positions especially in combat scenarios
or getting close to objects if you're
not using a room scale set up test if
any of this makes you motion sick and
tweak your options accordingly look for
doors with handles and especially red
handles I know this sounds like a
no-brainer but the way half-life Alex
leads you from section to section is in
its visual cues
don't bother with doors that don't have
handles they won't open and there's
nothing that lies beyond them now you
want to be on the lookout for more than
just any old door handle if something
you can grip has red paint on it it's
important this is particularly relevant
to garage doors that require you to get
down to open and some cabinets that
contain critical items in later sections
of the game it's very important to keep
this in mind follow the circuits and
cables most of half-life Alex's puzzles
revolve around the multi-tool critical
path puzzles usually consist of rewiring
circuitry to power certain objects as
the game goes on these become more
complex and you'll have to be more
mindful of where these circuits lead you
can trace them or check where they are
inside the
walls by simply holding your multi-tool
against the wall
tracking the current flow is also
important as these puzzles begin to span
larger spaces similarly you'll want to
keep an eye out for where cables lead
and come from within the environment a
few puzzles may have you scratching your
head but if you keep an eye on clues
like cables and wiring these will
eventually guide you to the locations of
critical points and what you need to
interact with quick tip for spatial
puzzles there's one set of multi-tool
puzzles that require you to move one
node to another it starts with a few red
nodes that cause you to fail the puzzle
but ramps up in difficulty red nodes
start to move and leave dangerous trails
but you can take your time as long as
your multi-tool is disengaged you won't
fail the puzzle even as red notes over
over so those are some basic tips we
have to get you on the right path before
jumping into half-life Alex for more on
the game be sure to check out our full
review here on GameSpot
you